you can throttle conservative content
you can tell conservatives they can't
upload you can tell people who are
politically incorrect that they can
upload you can allow pedophiles to
upload to YouTube kids all you want but
you have to disclose it to your user
base net neutrality so before we move on
I gather this is a sensitive topic I
want you to answer the question of the
day but I want you to watch this entire
video first not only am I asking you
what's your opinion on net neutrality
everyone's doing that like what's your
opinion but what's your opinion on
today's sort of selective corporate
outrage because that's what's
surrounding net neutrality right now is
outraged over corporations their control
over the internet while ignoring the
world's biggest corporations who are
ardent supporters of net neutrality and
that's something that concerns me and
gets a little lost in the cracks both
sides have arguments with merit so I
want to kind of get into those who are
very Pro net neutrality and why they
believe so and why there's the Liberty
to it listen I'm gonna roll a clip here
and it's not because I don't like
Phillip DeFranco I actually really like
Phillip DeFranco I think he's one of the
few and fair-minded people on the
internet he's been been invited on the
show hopefully we'll have him on soon
I'm actually rolling this clip of
Phillip DeFranco because he's talked
about net neutrality for a long time and
I think he's a pretty good
representative of how opposition to I
guess sort of the current allowing of
lapsing of legislation feels so let's
let him set up that side of the argument
a certain cell service says hey if you
go with us when you when you watch
Netflix that doesn't go towards your
data counter maybe it's with Hulu or
whoever now imagine your broadband
internet right in your home all of a
sudden you have Comcast they say hey
guess what when you use whoo you got the
top tier the premium speed and they have
an incentive they own a good percentage
of Hulu but then guess what Netflix
Amazon Prime those places those places
don't get our fast lane for the Internet
it's slower it's clunkier maybe hey
maybe if Netflix our Amazon Prime they
pay us we'll give them the fast lane you
gotta pay a tax if you want to go over a
fast lane break
imagine if Comcast's or another isp
launched a competitor to youtube and
then they could just slow down the
speeds to youtube for their customer
which you could argue and the chairman
of the FCC now does well hey if an isp
is going to do that the market will
decide we don't want Comcast the market
will keep companies honest and fair and
know you know how many people have
Comcast and they
don't want Comcast but they have to have
Comcast because there aren't really any
other option okay I like Philip DeFranco
but there's an irony there that we're
looking at the same argument and seeing
an entirely different conclusion he's
saying could you imagine if your
broadband company did what your mobile
carrier company did I'm going could you
imagine if broadband was finally as good
as the mobile carrier um any he's
talking about creating a competitor to
Google to YouTube yeah and this is a guy
who's been very outspoken as we have
about YouTube selectively curating and
censoring people so I'm gonna come back
to that which is also I find it kind of
odd when people just gloss over
something here's clip B Google issued a
statement saying the FCC's net
neutrality rules are working well for
consumers and we're disappointed in the
proposal released today Google huge
supporter net neutrality we'll come back
to that and go why because it shouldn't
really affect them directly okay few
claims that come from net neutrality
before I get to that let me set up a
world you here's what I think is
important okay and again please just
hold hold your thoughts this is meant to
be a discussion on net neutrality
because there are reasonable voices on
both sides of this issue it is nuanced
and anytime you get into tech dialogue
people can get really confused yeah so
we're going to try to avoid doing that
here's the deal do you believe that
human beings are inherently prone to
corruption yes okay so do I do you
believe that corporations are inherently
prone to corruption yes do you believe
that people slash corporations are
inherently prone to corruption the
bigger and more powerful they get yes we
both agree now do you believe the only
exception to that is YouTube Google
Facebook and the United States federal
government if not you're gonna have some
some apprehension about net neutrality
okay that's that's where the worldview
comes in so let's look at it through
that lens here are some of the things
that people claim with net neutrality we
need net neutrality because there aren't
enough ISP choices and it's service
providers in the market as I said they
don't have it only has power if there
are enough choices okay yeah do you know
who actually would most benefit and most
love to see net neutrality repealed
small rural ISPs that's something a lot
of people don't talk about just Verizon
Comcast AT&T it's easy to talk about big
evil corporations and not talk about the
smaller company some extended benefits
so net neutrality can really harm
smaller ISPs under net neutrality as
have them now ISPs up to smoke for
submit proposals for any new technology
or I think it's new technology or
business model it's the exact quote so
on top of all the red tape right in all
of the costs the burning costs the FCC
can also turn down proposals without
giving the company any opportunity to
appeal does that sound like fostering
innovation is that's like something that
would encourage competition we also hear
that we need to impose monopoly laws on
ISPs in areas where there's a little
competition so this goes back to kind of
telecom communication companies right
pedal to regulating them like that a lot
of people have talked about regulating
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter as
telecommunication companies under title
2 and I've defended them and said no I
don't think anyone should force them to
treat content equally but that ties in
to why there's a reason that they
actually support net neutrality we'll
come back to that so um there's actually
this article from Fast Company and this
is what they write about they write
about a company what's name of the
company I think it's that one cable one
cable one right so you talk about cable
uncovering being the only option right
for for broadband in rural areas okay
and so this is an article that they
write about they talk about how if they
were regulated under title to its
telecommunication companies well the
government would actually be able to set
the rates because cable one keeps
raising the prices and they keep raising
the price is why because they're the
only one there so they say that they're
raising prices now that being said their
prices are some around 80 dollars per
month which is actually pretty much
right middle-of-the-road it's not like
it's completely outlandish but these
articles that have been sent to me by
fatzke I've had this sent to me a dozen
times think about this for a second
let's assume okay the smaller rural isp
cable one is evil and their only goal is
to screw people and that's what they're
jacking up prices what happens if the
government does set rates on cable one
I'm asking this gentleman what do you
think happens do you think that if
there's a set ceiling cable one is going
to be providing better internet do you
think they're gonna be upgrading their
servers do you think the reuptake are
their abilities they're gonna be
upgrading their speeds are gonna be
creating better packages or if the rates
are set do you think it's more likely
that they're just gonna say alright this
is let me ask it's do you think it's
more or less likely if the rate is set
in that area let's say rural Mississippi
for another competing ISP to come in
and make a killing putting cable one out
of business where is it more or less
likely for those people to get better
internet service another claim they'll
hear a lot is if we repeal net
neutrality there will be separate
packages right this is one filter
Frankel um people talk about internet
access video streaming emails and it'll
be split up that they'll be throttled
right there's a slippery slope without a
lot of support there are only two
instances and they're a little more
complicated than people let on I think
was Comcast with Netflix and AT&T had a
huge fine for throttling people with
their unlimited putting that them back
down to slower speeds yeah um but all of
that was corrected not because of
legislation but because it was
immediately made public and it was so
toxic that people started dropping their
plans the market was piss the market was
pissed mobile data plans remember how
they used to be so extremely limited
they were patent and people now are
fearing that broadband packages will be
like that without net neutrality where
have you seen more competition where
have you seen your rates become more
competitive your plan become better your
mobile data plan or broadband but you're
paying for right now because now mobile
plans are unlimited with faster and
faster speeds thanks to a free market
another claim that we hear a lot is that
we have to have net neutrality because
big evil corporations people think well
because variety because a big company
supports it it must be bad but then
there's another big company that
supports them and in this case you have
the world's biggest companies in Google
and Facebook who by the way unlike the
ISPs they have a long and storied
history of dishonest censorship and
throttling and content favoritism
Facebook alone I don't know how many
tens of times and this begs the question
why is Google YouTube and Facebook why
are these giant companies so adamant
about supporting that neutrality here's
something else crazy big companies like
Google they're not really customers of
ISPs they connect directly to the web
directly through an internet internet
exchange point so it doesn't directly
affect them but you'd be hard-pressed to
find people who would support regulating
YouTube Google certainly small
government libertarians is a
telecommunications company under the
guidelines that would basically force
them to allow all content to be uploaded
and distributed equally now but I would
support and this is a big step for a
libertarian small-government Liberty
like me under title 2 if we agree to
transparency loss which is a big part of
the repealing of net neutrality right
now it's okay listen you first off
they're still antitrust laws they're
still monopolies
so if you're the throttle which you're
not supposed to do you have to let your
customer base know that's a big part of
this legislation that's a big part of
this change is transparencies living
being given the priority now I would not
support regulating YouTube Facebook
Google under title 2 if it's you have to
treat all content equally right but I
would I would support putting them under
that kind of regulation if it just means
that they have to be transparent with
people using YouTube hey listen you can
throttle conservative content you can
tell conservatives they can't upload you
can tell people who are politically
incorrect if they can upload you can
allow pedophiles to upload to YouTube
kids all you want but you have to
disclose it to your user base and that's
why when you put the puzzle pieces
together and you think about it he alone
a second why would you tube in Google
and Facebook be such huge supporters of
net neutrality if it didn't affect them
I think it opens the door to people
saying hey we can regulate an industry
here just by ensuring that they are
transparent basically the government is
a referee at that point the government
is a referee with its whistle saying hey
you're breaking the rules there we're
gonna put you in the penalty box on the
other hand you have a fence right here
right you have a line so people talking
about evil corporations you're saying
okay this is the big evil corporations
are against net neutrality okay here's
the line on one side you do you have
Verizon yeah the AT&T of Comcast use
small rural ISPs only have a lot of
companies okay that's in this side one
on the other side you do have Google
YouTube Facebook and potentially the
federal government now the government is
not a referee it's not enforcing
transparency it's picking sides they
have buddies in their pocket the biggest
companies in the world if you want to
talk about monopolies I would certainly
say that Facebook and YouTube has more
of an ottoman ah Polly and that on the
transfer of information certainly media
than caves a lot more yeah households in
Missouri and they are so adamantly Pro
net neutrality because precisely if
people say well we can actually fix this
industry we can regulate it without
stepping in just making sure they're
following the rules just making sure
that they're disclosing with their
customers what they're doing guess what
you'd have a lot of people as a matter
of fact you'd have people line
to say let's apply those standards to
YouTube or Facebook no no let's not do
that let's look at the evil cellphone
companies who gave you unlimited data
and gave you free hotspots and gave you
free Spotify and free t-mobile and
Netflix downloading because they're the
bad guys they're the big evil
corporations Google Facebook we're the
mom-and-pop shop you don't need any
transparency with that so why comes back
down to the world view do you believe
that anyone is exempt from the
proclivity toward human corruption I
don't whether that's Comcast or Verizon
just like people who support net
neutrality I agree with you but I also
don't believe that Google Facebook and
YouTube have pure motives here nor the
big government legislators who want to
have their hands in the pocket hey did
you like this video of course you did
let's there's something wrong with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100% I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal you can leave a
thumbs up and subscribe